ici je vous parle souvent de smartphones
que ce soit du haut de gamme très haut
de gamme milieu de gamme et parfois
d'entrée de gamme et je voulais
justement faire une vidéo dédiée pour
vous dire comment réussir à prouver
votre smartphone plutôt dans l'entré
terre montrait dans une gamme de prix
pied assez basses aux alentours des 200
250 euros je sais ça reste quand même
beaucoup d'argent mais au vu d'un
smartphone nu on reste dans des tailles
qui sont quand même relativement
accessible j'ai donc développé une
méthode qui permettra de trouver un
smartphone pas cher et j'espère qu'il va
vous regarder toute la vidéo et bien
vous apporter beaucoup d'informations
pour trouver votre nouveau smartphone
ici c'est une bonne vieille méthode
inventée par monsieur re qui va
s'appeler la méthode où nous ramène aux
horaires à nora ça vous permet
d'identifier surtout 5 manière d'acheter
vos smartphones différemment facilement
de trouver au meilleur prix on va
commencer par développer le premier
point est le premier point cn pour 9 pas
le chiffre 9 mai le plus vous parlez
d'acheter un smartphone neuf autres
centres en ici sur l'entrée de gamme
vous voulez acheter un smartphone 9 vous
en doutez que aux alentours des 200 à
250 euros
vous n'allez pas trouver les smartphones
les plus haut de gamme avec un peu
grosse fiche technique
néanmoins je n'aime pas trop une source
intéressante est sûre ça je conseille
d'aller voir sur différents sites alors
bon il y en a plusieurs que je connais
vous pouvez aller sur boulanger vous
allez par exemple dans la barre de
recherche chercher smartphone vous allez
aussi de faire un tri sur le côté vous
avez les modèles vous avez les marques
le stockage tout ça tout ça on s'en
fiche nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
le prix et vous allez définir un prix
maximum allait investir 250 euros
j'envoie d'acheter un pack avec le aux
normes fixe qui ressort j'ai le paceman
z de l'année dernière qui est présent
galaxie à 859 euros galaxie à 40mm
beaucoup mieux 219 euros et à 15% de
remise donc là vous allez voir une liste
de tous les smartphones vous allez
pouvoir trouver en fait la même chose
sur le site de la fnac par exemple vous
cherchez smartphone vous venez vous
filtrez vous bcsa jusqu'à les pareils on
va se dire 250 euros c'est moins pas
très évident chez eux pour mieux filtrer
à les 231 euros est elle la même manière
d'être toute une liste de smartphones
somme toute assez récent et là vous
allez trouver des économies des bons
plans amazon qui regorge aussi vraiment
de bons plans là soit pas le filtrage
pas pris mais bon sur le principe c'est
sensiblement la même chose vous venez
vous cherchez outre votre bon plan il ya
pas mal de choses assez intéressantes
donc ça c'est pour lui elle ensuite vous
avez le haut pour deux
l'occasion par ici on est vraiment sur
l'occasion entre particuliers il ya donc
trois grands sites que je vais vous
présenter ici
le premier article que vous utilisez
peut-être c'est facebook facebook avec
sa marketplace
une fois sur la marketplace est la même
chose vous venez vous cherchez
smartphones oui ça nous proposera même
pas mal de choses et là vous allez
trouver des smartphones d'occasions
alors bien évidemment là dessus
attention il absolument aucune garantie
puisqu'on et deux particuliers à
particuliers demander vraiment de
pouvoir voir le smartphone si vous êtes
dans la même région vous déplacer pour
voir le produit fonctionnant directement
devant vous si vous n'êtes pas dans la
même région ont demandé à personne de se
connecter soit sur wat salle soit sur
messenger pour pouvoir voir le produit
fonctionnel le voir en gros plan et être
sûrs qu'ils fonctionnent mon avis est le
plus important
alors regardez juste un petit coup
d'oeil on va avoir de tout on va voir à
boire et à manger shiomi 2008 light ici
à 190 euros pourquoi pas un dodji s60
light 145 bon il faut vraiment faire
attention à ce qu'on a cherché échos
fusion 9 je suis pas sûr que ce soit
l'aide ce qui faillit partir aujourd'hui
vous allez prix mini prix maxi on va
dire prix mini 0 prix maxi on va se dire
200 euros iphone 5 50 euros vont il faut
le vouloir ça je ne vous le cache pas on
fait vous pouvez aussi sur ebay qui est
quand même aujourd'hui une des
plateformes à ces incontournables dans
ce domaine là et de la même manière vous
allez rechercher smartphone là vous avez
une gamme de prix vous pareil vous
mettez j'en sais rien moi de 50 à 200
euros et là vous être pas mal de choses
on retrouve toujours bien évidemment
choquée que leurs ennemis ne suit que
celle tew c'est le procès de parme n'a
pas espionné rapide d'informations
là-dessus ça sert tout cas demandé il ya
du suspens au méfiez-vous que sponsor
elle est toujours un petit peu ce qu'il
en est spawn suspens aux sponsors il ya
beaucoup de sponsors ici à la
d'occasions on va trouver un galaxy et
suite à 59 euros ça peut être pas mal
s'il est fonctionnel s'il marche très
bien et si ya pas de problème 60 euros
pour rexel suite ça peut être vraiment
un très bon plan et vous avez bien
évidemment le bon coin qui associe une
des grosses références vous cherchez
smartphones par région ou pas c'est un
principe vous filtrez pas repris et
venez trouver le smartphone qui vous
intéressent au meilleur prix d'ailleurs
si j'ai fait une vidéo pour savoir
comment vendre et à quel prix vendre vos
objets sur internet comment bien vendre
surtout ou vendre et par quels moyens de
paiement vous invite à aller voir la
vidéo la petite fille s'affiche comme ça
- vous serez tous le deuxième aussi plus
l'opportunité je sais une fois de plus
j'écris extrêmement mal je m'explique
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
plusieurs fois par an et bien il ya des
rats
il ya les soldes vous pouvez trouver les
fameuses soldes d'hiver les soldes d'été
surtout pour tout ce qui est
électronique vous avez le black friday
fin novembre où là vous avez vraiment
des prix cassés
on peut trouver des références
extrêmement intéressante à des prix
vraiment très très bas bien évidemment
il faut vous vouliez acheter un
smartphone à ce moment là généralement
on va pas forcément attendre le mois de
novembre pour venir faire de bonnes
affaires
mais si votre calendrier coïncide au
moment où se trouvaient des bonnes
affaires et notamment par rapport aux
malfrats idée ça vaut vraiment le coup
d'attendre quelques jours plus pour
vraiment venir des lissiers votre
nouveau smartphone un prix vraiment tout
va le rc pour l'heureux conditionner le
reconditionner c'est comme de l'occasion
sa peau c'est l'occasion de particuliers
et professionnels en gros vous avez
acheté un professionnel vous avez donc
derrière des garanties vous avez un
service j'avais un interlocuteur qui
sera obligé de vous répondre
et évidemment il faut identifier les
sites sérieux je présente deux solutions
sérieuses et à vous nous dire ce que
vous en pensez un banc commentaires le
premier c'est le français qui s'appelle
riz commerce et commerces une solution
qui assez intéressante vous chercher
dans tous les smartphones reconditionnés
vous avez dans la liste et là vous allez
voir pas mal de choses allaient pouvoir
avoir effectivement un filtre pas repris
alors ici on va se dire ah les prix aux
alentours de 200 euros c'est dommage
qu'ils aient pas de fourchette de prix
voyez où on puisse dire de cinq ans par
200 euros pour vous mettez un prix vous
était pas mal de possibilités et vous
rien qu'ici vous allez pouvoir trouver
pas mal d'iphone assez intéressant 6
aces 6 aces plus galaxy ace 6 edge
pourquoi pas quand elle fait ça me sauve
également il ya du s est que vous allez
trouver ici sont des smartphones qui
était haut de gamme à une époque et qui
maintenant sont disponibles à des tarifs
vraiment très très bas bien évidemment
sur des smartphones vieillissons j'ai
pas pouvoir faire tourner dessus
mais si par exemple vous voulez un
iphone et qu'on voulait avoir pour pas
trop cher et bien vous pouvez voir par
ce système là de la même manière c'est
pas trop des smartphones qui étaient des
smartphones milieu de gamme il ya
quelques temps et qui maintenant sont
invendables ou tarif d'entrée de gamme
à vous de vraiment faire refaire faut
vraiment prendre le temps pour aller
chercher votre iphone 7 ça peut être
assez intéressant comme référence iphone
et ce il ya onze pages en tout donc je
vous laisserai un petit peu faire un
tour par vous même vous avez également
date marque est aussi une des références
pour les produits reconditionnés et
notamment les smartphones et si vous
avez un petit bouton smart phones qui
lie à vous cliquez dessus on vient des
cendres et là on peut voir le prix max
est lassé par alsace et intuitif on
descend 255 euros
ok on infiltre va avoir des iphone 7 qui
vont sortir on va avoir du galaxy s et
galaxy ace 7 et de cette manière là ça
peut aussi être vraiment intéressant bon
là vous l'aurez compris je vous parle
d'occasions mais il nous reste une année
à l'être à faire c'est là le à ça
correspond aux anciens modèles
en fait vous explique le truc un peu la
même chose que le hand le neuf vous
allez acheter du neuf mais des modèles
d'années antérieures à la différence du
haut et du r qui sont tous les deux des
smartphones d'occasions mais là vous
pouvez carrément trouver des produits
qui sont neuf mais qu'il ne faut pas la
toute dernière référence
et c'est justement ce point là qui est
intéressant et je voulais vraiment le
détacher du côté neuf ans au parce
qu'ici le neuf c'est le dernier modèle
sur l'entrée de gamme
ici par contre et pour trouver des
produits haut de gamme milieu de gamme
beaucoup plus bas puisque oui vous le
savez quand un nouveau modèle arrive il
en poussant l'autre parfois l'ancien
modèle reste au catalogue des marques en
tout cas peuvent encore se retrouver sur
des sites marchands et on les trouve
bien évidemment bien moins cher et c'est
là vous pouvez en province marseille qui
a un an qui a deux ans un tarif beaucoup
plus bas qui est neuf qui n'a jamais
servi avec une batterie qui n'a jamais
été utilisée lors qu'ils auront une
durée de vie plus importante par rapport
à smartphones reconditionnés sauf dans
le calme pour reconditionner si la
batterie était déjà morte et qu'à ce
moment là
l'entreprise qu'il a reconditionné à
changer la batterie moyenne et enfin
vous comprenez un peu l'idée vous n'avez
pas trouvé l'iphone 10 à 150 euros ou à
200 euros aujourd'hui vous le toit quand
même un peu plus cher mais l'idée est là
c'est à dire vous pouvez regarder ce qui
se passe du côté de chez wang plus vous
pouvez regarder ce que vous allez
pouvoir prouver même du côté de chez
xiaomi ya probablement des références
intéressantes donc sans jamais vraiment
trouvé le smartphone qui vous intéresse
dans d'entrée de gamme un smartphone
avec des specs un peu plus haute un peu
plus performant mais qu'un smartphone
d'ancienne génération bien évidemment
ici avec le a avec le jeune hubert apple
avec mots et avec mon père je vais
pouvoir trouver des smartphones
d'occasions les smartphones qui ont déjà
vécu ce soit auprès du particulier avec
le haut d'occasion soit avec le r pour
reconditionner au niveau du
professionnel là j'aurai des garanties
donc il faut vraiment regarder une fois
de plus ce qui est relié par rapport à
votre budget et puis ensuite le haut
c'est l'opportunité
c'est notamment le black friday ou alors
les périodes de soldes ou si vous
trouvez des tarifs dédiés par exemple
y'a pas longtemps il y avait les xiaomi
days son site de la fnac peuvent y
trouver des smartphones qui ont mis un
peu moins cher toute l'année il ya des
bons plans de temps en temps il faut
rester à l'affût si vous êtes dans
l'optique de changer votre smartphone
n'hésitez pas à faire un tour complet
des différents marchands que ce soit à
boulanger soit fnac cdiscount que ce
soit à rue du commerce soit darty il y
en a beaucoup
allez jeter un petit coup d'oeil et là
encore je ne parle que sur les
revendeurs français allez voir aussi du
côté du reconditionner les voir sur les
différentes marketplace fait un tour
prenez le temps regardez ce qu'il en est
je suis sûr que si vous cherchez
vraiment sur ces cinq points
et bien vous allez trouver le smartphone
pas cher fait pour vous à vous de me
dire maintenant vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi ça c'est
cinq points sur cette méthode noura 19
ce que vous en pensez en va en
commentaire et si toutefois il ya des
choses qui vous intéressent vous le dis
bien évidemment des liens pour cliquer
et accéder plus rapidement en
descriptions sur ce je vous embrasse
donne rendez vous dès demain pour
continuer à parler tactique croyez moi
il ya plein de nouveautés qui sont
arrivés il ya quelque chose à raconter
et je pense que ça va être très sympa à
très bientôt jean bastien
[Musique]
ouais
ban